This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. In July 1980, a group of Salvadoran migrants crossed the border from Mexico into Arizona. They walked over an isolated mountain range and halfway across a wide desert valley. There were more than two dozen of them, people who had left behind lives and jobs to come to the United States. They'd hired some guides to lead them on the journey. Reporting our story this week is Delaney Hall. And those guides had brought them to a largely uninhabited part of the border. It was a vast, empty, and fatally hot stretch of the Sonoran Desert.
这里是 99% Invisible。我是罗曼·马尔斯。1980年7月，一群萨尔瓦多移民从墨西哥跨越边界进入亚利桑那州。他们翻越了一座人迹罕至的山脉，穿过了宽阔的沙漠河谷的一半。他们有二十多人，都是抛下了生活和工作来到美国的人。他们雇了一些向导来带领他们完成这段旅程。本周为我们报道这个故事的是德兰尼·霍尔。而那些向导把他们带到了边境一个几乎荒无人烟的地方。那是索诺拉沙漠一片广阔、空旷且酷热致命的区域。
The temperature of the next day got up to around 1,215 degrees out there. It was deadly. This is John Fife. He's a Presbyterian minister from Tucson, which is a couple of hours from where the migrants crossed. They were in the middle of the most desolate and deadly area of the desert. And I think out of the group of 26, 12 of them died the first day out.
那里的第二天温度飙升到了大约1,215度。这太致命了。这是约翰·法伊夫。他是来自图森的长老会牧师，图森距离移民过境的地方有几个小时的车程。他们当时身处沙漠中最荒凉、最致命的区域。我想在26人当中，有12人在出发的第一天就遇难了。
The survivors were eventually found, delirious and suffering from intense dehydration and heatstroke. Some of them had stripped off their clothes. Border Patrol agents brought them to a hospital in Tucson, which is where Reverend John Fife met them. And they asked some of us who were pastors to provide some pastoral care for the survivors who were traumatized beyond understanding. And they began to tell me why they'd fled El Salvador. At that point, Reverend Fife had lived in Tucson for more than ten years, leading a small congregation at a church called Southside Presbyterian. He didn't know much
幸存者最终被找到时，已经神志不清，并饱受严重脱水和中暑的折磨。他们中的一些人甚至脱掉了衣服。边境巡逻队特工将他们送往图森的一家医院，正是在那里，约翰·法伊夫牧师见到了他们。他们要求我们这些牧师为那些遭受了无法想象的创伤的幸存者提供一些牧养关怀。他们开始向我倾诉他们逃离萨尔瓦多的原因。当时，法伊夫牧师已经在图森生活了十多年，在一名为“南区长老会”的教堂领导一个小型会众。他对这些并不太了解
about Central America or what was going on in countries like Nicaragua, Guatemala and El Salvador around this time. Not only ignorant but I couldn't have put El Salvador on a map. I knew it was somewhere between Mexico and Panama but that was the extent of my knowledge. So I had a lot to learn and a lot of catching up to do. The people of El Salvador are caught in a web of terror, trapped between the military forces of the Iranian government and the guerrilla forces of the FMLN. No one is safe in this civil war. El Salvador's civil war had been decades in the making.
中美洲的事情，也不知道在这个时期像尼加拉瓜、危地马拉和萨尔瓦多这样的国家正在发生什么。不仅无知，而且我根本在地图上找不出萨尔瓦多。我知道它大概在墨西哥和巴拿马之间，但我的认知也就仅限于此了。所以我有很多东西要学，有很多空白需要填补。萨尔瓦多人民陷入了一张恐怖的网中，夹在伊朗政府的军事力量和法拉本多·马蒂民族解放阵线（FMLN）的游击队之间。在这场内战中没有人是安全的。萨尔瓦多的内战经历了数十年的酝酿。
Since the early 1900s, the country had been ruled by a series of oligarchs and corrupt military leaders. They maintained control by repressing large segments of the rural population. In the late 1970s and early 1980s, a number of left-wing guerrilla groups began to grow in power and influence. The military responded by trying to crush this resistance.
自20世纪初以来，该国一直由一系列寡头和腐败的军事领袖统治。他们通过镇压大部分农村人口来维持控制。在20世纪70年代末和80年代初，许多左翼游击组织开始壮大并扩大影响力。军方则试图通过镇压这种抵抗来进行回应。
Death squads targeted union leaders, community organizers, and other people they suspected of sympathizing with the guerrillas. That included priests and nuns. Lots of civilians were caught in the middle of this violence. Thousands of people were disappeared, murdered, or displaced. Today, the Salvadoran people continue to suffer as a persistent pattern of brutal human rights violations
行刑队将枪口对准了工会领袖、社区组织者以及其他被怀疑同情游击队的人。这其中也包括神父和修女。许多平民被卷入了这场暴力的漩涡之中。成千上万的人失踪、被谋杀或流离失所。如今，随着持续不断的残酷侵犯人权行为，萨尔瓦多人民仍在继续受苦
grips the nation. And El Salvador wasn't the only country where this was happening. Similar conflicts were unfolding in Nicaragua and Guatemala, where authoritarian governments were facing pressure from left- wing rebels. This is the history Reverend John Fife started to learn about. When he met the Salvadoran migrants who'd nearly died in the desert near Tucson.
笼罩着这个国家。萨尔瓦多并不是唯一一个发生这种事情的国家。类似的冲突也在尼加拉瓜和危地马拉上演，那里的威权政府正面临来自左翼叛军的压力。这就是约翰·法伊夫牧师开始了解的历史。当他遇到差点在图森附近的沙漠中丧生的萨尔瓦多移民时。
Well, basically, they were telling me why they'd fled El Salvador. About threats from death squads, killings of members of their family or close friends, that sort of thing. And the reason why they'd had to flee. He didn't know it then, but Reverend Fife was witnessing the beginning of something big. Hundreds of thousands of Central Americans were trying to get away from these dangerous and bloody civil wars. They were fleeing their countries, making their way through Mexico and crossing into the United States.
嗯，基本上，他们是在告诉我他们逃离萨尔瓦多的原因。关于遭到行刑队威胁的经历，家庭成员或挚友被杀害的事情，诸如此类。以及他们不得不逃亡的原因。他当时并不知道，法伊夫牧师正在见证一件大事的开端。数十万中美洲人正试图逃离这些危险而血腥的内战。他们逃离自己的国家，经由墨西哥辗转进入美国。
So, a major migration of refugees occurred along this border during that 10-year period, beginning in 1980. Reverend Fife's church sat less than 100 miles from the border, and it would be completely swept up in this crisis. Eventually, five in his congregants would give shelter to hundreds of Central Americans, they'd be joined by a network of churches across the country, all opening their doors and giving migrants a safe place to stay. This would mark the beginning of a new and controversial social movement based on the old religious concept of sanctuary, the idea that churches have a duty
因此，从1980年开始的这十年里，沿着这条边境发生了一场重大的难民移民潮。法伊夫牧师的教堂距离边境不到100英里，它将被彻底卷入这场危机之中。最终，他会众中的五个人将为数百名中美洲人提供庇护，他们将得到全国各地一个教堂网络的加入，所有这些教堂都敞开大门，为移民提供一个安全的地方居住。这将标志着一场新的、充满争议的社会运动的开始，该运动基于古老的宗教避难概念，即教堂有义务
to shelter people fleeing persecution. More than 6,000 people have signed up to provide sanctuary around the country. So, today cracks down on so-called sanctuary cities. There are... There's been a lot of talk about sanctuary in the news recently. And the modern movement in the US can trace its roots back to Reverend Fife. We're going to spend the next two episodes
为逃避迫害的人提供庇护。全国各地已有6,000多人报名提供庇护。因此，如今开始打压所谓的避难城市。有……最近新闻里有很多关于避难的讨论。而美国现代运动的根源可以追溯到法伊夫牧师。我们将在接下来的两集中
looking at how the Sanctuary movement started and how it caused one of the biggest showdowns between church and state in recent history. After that first encounter with the Salvadorans at the hospital, Reverend Fife began to see more and more Central Americans arriving in Tucson. Some of them would come to his church and ask for help. And at first his inclination was to work within the rules of the immigration system. I was pretty naive at that point.
探讨庇护运动是如何开始的，以及它是如何引发近期历史上教会与国家之间最大规模的对峙之一的。在医院与萨尔瓦多人进行最初的接触后，法伊夫牧师开始看到越来越多的中美洲人抵达图森。他们中的一些人会来到他的教堂寻求帮助。起初，他的倾向是在移民系统的规则内行事。我当时相当天真。
And I went to the immigration office here in Tucson, met with the director and said, we're seeing refugees who are fleeing for their lives. What do we need to do to protect them? And he said, well, we have good political asylum law in the books. And if they're deserving of political asylum, if they're refugees, they'll get political asylum. A asylum you apply for if you are within the United States and have a well-founded fear of persecution, I'm talking law here. This is Ruth Ann Meyers.
我去了图森这里的移民办公室，与负责人见了面，说：“我们看到难民为了保命而逃亡。我们需要做什么来保护他们？”他说：“嗯，我们有很好的政治庇护法律。如果他们理应获得政治庇护，如果他们是难民，他们就会得到政治庇护。”如果你在美国境内并且对遭受迫害有合理的恐惧，你就会申请庇护，我这里说的是法律。这是鲁思·安·迈尔斯。
I was district director of the Immigration and Naturalization Service for Arizona in 1984 and a couple years later they added Nevada. Since 1980, when Congress passed the Refugee Act, the U.S. has asked people to meet a number of requirements in order to be granted political asylum. They have to establish that they fear persecution in their home country, based on their race, religion, nationality, political opinion, or social group. They also have to convince immigration that their government is actually involved in their persecution, or that it can't control the groups that are. If someone shows up in the U.S. and they can meet those requirements, they're supposed to be able to stay, but it's not always that simple.
我于1984年担任亚利桑那州移民归化局的地区主管，几年后他们又加上了内华达州。自1980年国会通过《难民法》以来，美国一直要求人们满足多项要求才能获得政治庇护。他们必须证明自己因为种族、宗教、国籍、政治见解或社会群体而害怕在祖国受到迫害。他们还必须让移民部门相信他们的政府实际上参与了对他们的迫害，或者政府无法控制那些参与迫害的群体。如果有人出现在美国并且符合这些要求，他们理应能够留下来，但这并不总是那么简单。
Myers used to interview people seeking asylum, and she says it could be tough to establish a person's status. It relied heavily on a single individual's testimony about what they'd been through. It depends on the individual. It depends on what they say and how they say it. And if they have any backing, so basically it was my decision based on my experience and what the person said. Because as you can understand There was very little physical evidence of this
迈尔斯过去常常采访寻求庇护的人，她说要确立一个人的身份可能很艰难。这很大程度上依赖于单个个人对自己经历的证词。这取决于个人。这取决于他们说什么以及他们怎么说。他们是否有任何支持，所以基本上这是根据我的经验以及当事人所说的话做出的决定。因为正如你所能理解的，这方面的物证非常少
Despite the challenges of qualifying for asylum Reverend five in his church raised some money and organized legal assistance for the migrants They started visiting detention centers and helping people fill out asylum applications They'd range for lawyers to represent them in court But it began to seem like even the people who met the requirements for a asylum were not getting it, like even in cases where there was physical evidence. I can remember taking in a guy who had been tortured in El Salvador, and we flew in and amnesty international doctor who testified that the, yeah, this guy's been tortured.
尽管获得庇护面临种种挑战，法伊夫五世和他的教堂还是筹集了一些资金，并为移民组织了法律援助。他们开始访问拘留中心，帮助人们填写庇护申请。他们会安排律师在法庭上代表他们。但渐渐地，似乎连那些符合庇护要求的人也无法获得庇护，即使在有物证的情况下也是如此。我记得曾收留过一个在萨尔瓦多遭受过酷刑的人，我们用飞机接来了一位国际特赦组织的医生，他作证说：“是的，这家伙确实遭受过酷刑。”
I'm an expert on the physical effects of torture. And the immigration judge would order him to port it the next day. Reverend V began to wonder what was behind these decisions to deport. Central Americans hoping for asylum faced some significant hurdles. For one thing, just as they began turning up along the US Mexico border in 1980, tens of thousands of refugees from other places like Cuba and Iran were also seeking refuge in the United States. The government was overwhelmed with applications. Most Central Americans had also historically come to the US for jobs, not because of political
我是酷刑身体影响方面的专家。而移民法官会在第二天命令将他驱逐出境。法伊夫牧师开始思考这些驱逐决定背后的原因。希望获得庇护的中美洲人面临着一些重大障碍。一方面，就在他们于1980年开始出现在美墨边境时，来自古巴和伊朗等其他地方的数万名难民也在美国寻求庇护。政府被申请淹没了。从历史上看，大多数中美洲人来美国也是为了工作，而不是因为政治
persecution. The government was more inclined to see them as economic migrants. And on top of that, there was the Cold War. Mr. Speaker, distinguished members of the Congress, I've got to say, I've got to say, I've got to say, I've got to say, I've got to say, I've got to say, I've got to say, I've got to say, I've got to say, I've got to say, I've got to say, I've got to say, I've got to say, I've got to say, I've got to say, I've got to say, I've got to say, I've got to say, I've got to say, I've got to say, I've got to say, I've got to say, I've got to say, I've got to say, I've got to say, I've got to say, I've got to say, I've got to say, I've got to say, I've got to say, I've got to say, I've got to say, I've got to say, I've got to say, I've got to say, I've got to say, I've got to say, I've got to say, I've got to say, I've got to say, I've got to say, I've got to say, I've got to say, I've got to say, I've got to say, I've got to say, I've got to say, I've got to say, I've got to say, I've got to say, I've got to say, I've got to say, I've got to say, I've got to say, I've got to say, I've got to say, I've got to say, I've got to say, I've got to say, I've got to say, I've got to say, I've got to say, I've got to say, I've got to say, I've got to say, I've got to say, I've got to say, I've got to say, I've got to say, I've got to say, I've got to say, I've got to say, down below Mexico that can't possibly constitute a threat to our well-being. And that's why I've asked for this session. Central America's problems do directly affect the security and the well-being of our own people. And Central America is an important front in the Cold War. A region so close to the U.S. that our national security required us to stop communist movements
受到迫害。政府更倾向于将他们视为经济移民。最重要的是，当时正处于冷战时期。议长先生，国会的各位杰出成员，我必须说，我必须说，我必须说，我必须说，我必须说，我必须说，我必须说，我必须说，我必须说，我必须说，我必须说，我必须说，我必须说，我必须说，我必须说，我必须说，我必须说，我必须说，我必须说，我必须说，我必须说，我必须说，我必须说，我必须说，我必须说，我必须说，我必须说，我必须说，我必须说，我必须说，我必须说，我必须说，我必须说，我必须说，我必须说，我必须说，我必须说，我必须说，我必须说，我必须说，我必须说，我必须说，我必须说，我必须说，我必须说，我必须说，我必须说，我必须说，我必须说，我必须说，我必须说，我必须说，我必须说，我必须说，我必须说，我必须说，我必须说，我必须说，我必须说，我必须说，我必须说，我必须说，我必须说，我必须说，我必须说，我必须说，我必须说，我必须说，我必须说，我必须说，我必须说，我必须说，我必须说，我必须说，我必须说，我必须说，在墨西哥南部，这绝不可能对我们的福祉构成威胁。这就是为什么我要求召开这次会议。中美洲的问题确实直接影响到我们自己人民的安全和福祉。中美洲是冷战中的一个重要前线。这个地区距离美国如此之近，以至于我们的国家安全要求我们阻止共产主义运动
from flourishing there. Nicaragua is just as close to Miami, San Antonio, San Diego and Tucson as those cities are to Washington where we're gathered tonight. Just a few years earlier, in 1979, a socialist revolution actually did happen in Nicaragua. The Sandinista National Liberation Front had ousted a U.S. backed dictatorship, which enrolled the country for decades. At the time of this speech, the Reagan administration was sending aid to Contras fighting the new socialist Sandinista government, and the U.S. was also doing its best to suppress similar left-wing movements in El Salvador and
在那里蓬勃发展。尼加拉瓜距离迈阿密、圣安东尼奥、圣迭戈和图森的距离，就如同这些城市距离我们今晚聚在一起的华盛顿一样近。就在几年前的1979年，尼加拉瓜确实发生了一场社会主义革命。桑地诺民族解放阵线推翻了统治该国数十年的美国支持的独裁政权。在这场演讲发表时，里根政府正在向与新的社会主义桑地诺政府作战的反政府武装（Contras）提供援助，美国也尽最大努力镇压萨尔瓦多和
Guatemala, which went backing the authoritarian governments that still had a grip on power in those countries. In summation, I say to you that tonight there can be no question, the national security of all the Americas is at stake in Central America. Thank you. I bless you, good luck. So here's how this all connects back to Tucson and the deportations that Reverend Fife was seeing Because the US government considered the governments of El Salvador and Guatemala to be political allies in the fight against communism
危地马拉存在着类似的左翼运动，这实际上是在支持那些在这些国家仍然把持着权力的独裁政府。总而言之，我要对你们说，今晚毫无疑问，整个美洲的国家安全都在中美洲危在旦夕。谢谢你们。上帝保佑你们，祝你们好运。所以这就是这一切如何与图森以及法伊夫牧师所看到的驱逐出境联系起来的。因为美国政府认为萨尔瓦多和危地马拉政府在反对共产主义的斗争中是政治盟友
It denied these governments were persecuting their own people De Regan almost all Salvadoran and Guatemala border crossers were classified not as political refugees But as economic migrants that meant they didn't qualify for asylum Salvatore and Guadalman border crossers were classified not as political refugees, but as economic migrants. That meant they didn't qualify for asylum. They got sent back. Ruth Ann Meyers, the former INS director in Arizona, says immigration officers followed policy set by the government, which has broad discretion when it comes to asylum decisions.
它否认这些政府在迫害自己的人民。在里根政府时期，几乎所有萨尔瓦多和危地马拉的越境者都被归类为经济移民，而不是政治难民。这意味着他们没有资格获得庇护。萨尔瓦多和危地马拉的越境者被归类为经济移民，而不是政治难民。这意味着他们没有资格获得庇护。他们被遣送回去了。亚利桑那州前移民归化局（INS）局长鲁思·安·迈尔斯表示，移民官员遵循的是政府制定的政策，在涉及庇护决定时，政府拥有广泛的自由裁量权。
The immigration officers, whether it be enforcement or the asylum officers or whatever, were not making up their criteria or the law. This all came from Congress. The result of this policy was stark when it came to Salvadorans and Guatemalans. Between 1983 and 1986, fewer than 3% of Salvadorans in Guatemalans who applied for asylum were approved. In that same period, the approval rate for Iranians was 60%. For Afghans fleeing the Soviet invasion, it was close to 40%. Back in Tucson, that put Reverend Fife and his congregants in a tough position.
移民官员，无论是执法人员还是庇护官员或其他人员，都没有凭空捏造他们的标准或法律。这一切都来自国会。当涉及萨尔瓦多人和危地马拉人时，这项政策的结果是严峻的。在1983年至1986年间，申请庇护的萨尔瓦多人和危地马拉人中，获批的比例不到3%。在同一时期，伊朗人的获批率为60%。对于为躲避苏联入侵而逃亡的阿富汗人来说，这一比例接近40%。回到图森，这把法伊夫牧师和他的会众置于一个艰难的境地。
They didn't want to encourage migrants to report immigration when they knew it was almost certain they'd be deported. So they held a series of meetings to figure out what to do. And that's when Jim Corbett started showing up. It's hard to describe Jim because he was a unique figure. Jim Corbett died in 2001, but back in the 80s, he lived on the edge of Tucson. He raised goats and he knew a lot about philosophy.
他们不想鼓励移民去向移民部门报到，因为他们知道几乎可以肯定会被驱逐出境。于是他们举行了一系列会议来商讨对策。就在那时，吉姆·科比特开始出现了。很难形容吉姆，因为他是一个独一无二的人物。吉姆·科比特于2001年去世，但在80年代，他住在图森的边缘。他养山羊，而且精通哲学。
He was also a quaker, and as the refugee crisis in Tucson continued to grow, Jim's religious faith compelled him to take action. He'd started letting refugees stay at his house, and in some of the ramshackle trailers scattered around his property. So Jim starts coming to meetings as house side-price butarian church where they're discussing the deportations. And after one of those meetings, Jim comes up to Reverend V. And his contention at that point to me was, John, I don't think we have any choice under
他也是一名贵格会教徒，随着图森难民危机的不断加剧，吉姆的宗教信仰驱使他采取行动。他开始让难民住在自己家里，以及散落在他房产周围的一些简陋拖车里。于是吉姆开始来到南区长老会教堂的会议上，他们在那里讨论驱逐出境的问题。在其中一次会议之后，吉姆走到法伊夫牧师面前。他当时的观点是：“约翰，在这种情况下，我认为我们别无选择，只能开始秘密将人们安全地带过边境，这样他们就不会被抓获、拘留和驱逐。”我的回应是：“吉姆，你到底是怎么想的？”然后他作了解释。
the circumstances, except to begin to smuggle people safely across the border so that they're not captured and detained and deported. My response was how the hell do you figure that, Jim? And he explained. Jim explained that they needed to consider two moments in history. The first was back in the 1800s, when church people, a lot of them Quakers, helped move runaway slaves across state lines and through the underground railroad to safety.
吉姆解释说，他们需要考虑历史上的两个时刻。第一个是在19世纪，当时教会的人（其中许多是贵格会教徒）帮助逃亡的奴隶跨越州界，通过地下铁路走向安全。
And he basically said, we have to conclude from history that they got it right. Those were the folks who understood and got it right. Then Jim pointed to the church and its failure to protect Jewish people fleeing the Holocaust in the 1930s and 40s. Many Jews were detained and deported back to Germany where they were killed. Jim argued that Christians should have done more to protect them. And he said they failed. They failed completely.
他基本上说，我们必须从历史中得出结论，他们做对了。那些人理解并做对了。然后吉姆指出了教会及其在20世纪30年代和40年代未能保护逃离大屠杀的犹太人的失败。许多犹太人被拘留并被驱逐回德国并在那里被杀害。吉姆认为，基督徒本应做更多的事情来保护他们。他说他们失败了。他们彻底失败了。
As people of faith faith as the church. And I said, yeah, you're right. And his punchline was, John, I don't think we can allow that to happen on our border and in our time. And after a couple of sleepless nights, I went back to him and said, yeah, you're right. I cannot be a pastor of a church here on the border and not do what you're asking. So, sign me up.
作为有信仰的人，作为教会。我说：“是的，你是对的。”他的妙语是：“约翰，我认为我们不能允许这种事在我们的边境和我们的时代发生。”在经历了几个不眠之夜后，我回到他身边说：“是的，你是对的。我不能在这里做边境上一座教堂的牧师，却不做你要求的事。所以，算我一个。”
At this point, Jim Corbett had already done some border runs on his own, picking up migrants in Mexico and helping them cross the border into the United States. But now, Reverend Fife and a handful of others started helping him. At first, they'd bring people across and put them up at Jim's house, but it quickly became clear they needed more space. So once again, Jim came to talk with Revereign 5. He wanted the church to start hosting people. That was a question that the whole congregation had to deal with.
此时，吉姆·科比特已经自己进行过一些越境行动，在墨西哥接上移民并帮助他们越境进入美国。但现在，法伊夫牧师和少数其他人开始协助他。起初，他们把人带过来并安置在吉姆家里，但很快就很明显，他们需要更多空间。于是吉姆再次来找法伊夫牧师谈话。他希望教堂开始接待难民。这是全体会众不得不面对的一个问题。
And that's not an easy choice for people to make. They talked and prayed, and then voted to let Central American refugees stay at the church. Soon on any given night, the church would have dozens of people sleeping in the main gathering space. Church members would provide food, clothes,
对人们来说，这不是一个容易做出的选择。他们交谈、祈祷，然后投票决定让中美洲难民留在教堂里。很快，在任何给定的夜晚，教堂里都会有几十个人睡在主要聚会空间里。教会成员将提供食物、衣服、
English lessons, medical care, and access to legal advice. They'd help the refugees strategize about what to do next. It wasn't as if the migrants were entirely safe. They were still undocumented and faced possible deportation. But they had access to resources, guidance, and a place to stay. The congregation at Southside was drawing on a long religious tradition when they decided to take the refugees into their church. It's actually an ancient tradition of temples and churches and synagogues and sacred sites of indigenous peoples that goes back as far as any history we know about. In Greek and Roman history, people who were threatened with persecution could find protection in temples. When the Roman Empire became Christian, churches took on the same function.
英语课程、医疗护理以及获得法律建议的途径。他们将帮助难民策划下一步该怎么做。这并不是说移民是绝对安全的。他们仍然是没有身份的人，面临着被驱逐出境的可能。但他们可以获得资源、指导和一个落脚的地方。南区教堂的会众在决定将难民接纳到他们的教堂时，借鉴了悠久的宗教传统。这实际上是寺庙、教堂、犹太会堂以及土著人民神圣场所的一项古老传统，其历史可以追溯到我们所知的任何历史。在希腊和罗马历史中，面临迫害威胁的人可以在寺庙中找到庇护。当罗马帝国成为基督教国家时，教堂承担了相同的功能。
The concept of sanctuary can also be found in medieval canon law and British common law. And as nation states evolved in Europe, some of those nations legally recognized the right of churches to shelter people. More recently, churches sheltered conscientious objectors during the Vietnam War. But even though Reverend Fife was drawing on a long religious tradition, he and his congregants were still harboring undocumented immigrants who crossed into the country illegally, and as it turns out, the government was keeping an eye on their growing operation.
庇护的概念也可以在中世纪的教会法和英国普通法中找到。随着欧洲民族国家的演变，其中一些国家在法律上承认了教堂庇护人们的权利。最近，教堂在越南战争期间庇护了拒绝服兵役者。但尽管法伊夫牧师借鉴了悠久的宗教传统，他和他的会众仍然在窝藏非法越境进入该国的无证移民，事实证明，政府一直在密切关注他们不断壮大的行动。
Well, what do we do under those circumstances? And the only conclusion we came to was, well, the only choice we have is to go public with what we're doing. They thought maybe by going public, the church could generate attention and public support. They invited a couple of other churches Church could generate attention and public support. They invited a couple of other churches to join them in a public announcement, and in March
那么，在这种情况下我们该怎么办？我们得出的唯一结论是，唯一的选择就是把我们正在做的事公之于众。他们认为也许通过公开，教堂能够引起关注并获得公众的支持。他们邀请了其他几家教堂加入他们的公开声明中，并在3月
of 1982, they hung two huge banners on the front of the Church. They said, in Spanish, this is a sanctuary of God for the oppressed of Central America. And immigration, do not profane the sanctuary of God. They held a service and publicly welcomed a new family from El Salvador to join the other refugees who are staying at the church. And they staged a press conference to explain exactly what the sanctuary movement was and what their goals were.
1982年，他们在教堂正面挂了两条巨大的横幅。上面用西班牙语写着：“这是上帝为中美洲受压迫者提供的避难所。移民部门，请不要亵渎上帝的避难所。”他们举行了一场礼拜仪式，公开欢迎来自萨尔瓦多的一户新家庭加入其他滞留在教堂的难民。他们还举行了一场新闻发布会，确切地解释了庇护运动是什么以及他们的目标是什么。
So yeah, we, we made some national news. In the American Southwest, the sanctuary movement has become a highly emotional issue. Supporters of that movement, mainly church people, help refugees from Central America. All members of the so-called sanctuary movement that offers aid, comfort, and shelter to illegal aliens from the same. About 200 churches across the United States have joined the sanctuary movement, vowing to violate the laws if necessary.
所以，是的，我们登上了一些全国新闻。在美国西南部，庇护运动已经成了一个高度感性的议题。该运动的支持者，主要是教会人士，帮助来自中美洲的难民。所有所谓庇护运动的成员，都为来自该地区的非法外国人提供援助、慰藉和庇护。全美大约有200家教堂加入了庇护运动，发誓如有必要将违反法律。
As the movement gained visibility, it became more controversial. The federal government contends conscience is not a good excuse for violating the law. Our objection to any such movement is that it takes the law into its own hands. They are not wrong. Despite these government objections, the movement continued to grow.
随着该运动知名度的提高，它也变得更具争议性。联邦政府认为，良知不是违反法律的好借口。我们对任何此类运动的反对都在于它凌驾于法律之上。他们没有错。尽管政府反对，该运动仍在继续发展。
More and more churches in Senegal started to get in touch with Reverend Fife. They'd call us and say, can you send us a family? We're going to declare sanctuary. A network started to develop, which meant Reverend Fife and Jim Corbett had to figure out how to safely transport refugees across the country to the churches that could support them. And so Jim and I basically sat down here with a map of the United States and said, okay, who do you know in Albuquerque and who do you know in Denver and who do you know in
塞内加尔越来越多的教堂开始与法伊夫牧师取得联系。他们会打电话给我们说：“你们能给我们送一个家庭来吗？我们要宣布建立庇护所。”一个网络开始形成，这意味着法伊夫牧师和吉姆·科比特必须弄清楚如何安全地将难民跨国运送到能够支持他们的教堂。于是吉姆和我基本上拿着一张美国地图坐在这里说：“好吧，你在阿尔伯克基认识谁，你在丹佛认识谁，你在……认识谁”
across the United States so we could move people. And we literally in one afternoon figured out an underground railroad and we modeled it on the old underground railroad. By the mid-1980s, hundreds of churches and synagogues across the country had joined the sanctuary movement. Almost every mainstream church denomination had gotten involved, including Lutherans, Methodists, and Baptists. Sanctuary volunteers came from a wide variety of political viewpoints, including conservative, but everyone shared a belief that churches needed to respond to the Central American crisis. These American churches were connected to a network of churches that extended down into Mexico and Central America. So migrants could plug into this network and make their way north. Some would find shelter in Mexico, others would continue into the US.
遍布全美，这样我们就能转移人员。我们实际上在一个下午就构想出了一条地下铁路，并且我们以旧的地下铁路为原型。到20世纪80年代中期，全国数以百计的教堂和犹太会堂加入了庇护运动。几乎所有主流基督教教派都参与其中，包括路德宗、卫理公会和浸信会。庇护志愿者来自各种各样的政治立场，包括保守派，但每个人都有一个共同的信念，即教堂需要对中美洲危机做出回应。这些美国教堂与延伸至墨西哥和中美洲的教堂网络相连。因此，移民可以接入这个网络并向北前进。有些人会在墨西哥找到庇护，其他人则会继续进入美国。
That's exactly what Patricia Barcelo did. My name is Patricia Barcelo, I am a refugee from Maramala in I live in the United States since 1985. Patricia grew up in Guatemala City, and her parents were union organizers during the Civil War, which made them a target of the government. They labeled my dad and my mom as being involved in subversive acts
帕特里夏·巴塞洛正是这么做的。我叫帕特里夏·巴塞洛，我是来自马拉马拉的难民，我自1985年以来一直居住在美国。帕特里夏在危地马拉城长大，她的父母在内战期间是工会组织者，这使他们成为了政府的目标。他们给我的爸爸妈妈贴上了参与颠覆活动的标签
in wanting to overthrow the government. And that was enough for them to kill you, disappear you, or do whatever they wanted to do to you. At one point, Patricia's dad disappeared for many weeks. He'd been kidnapped by the military or the police. Patricia's family never learned exactly who. He came home being the shadow of a man that he was because he was so skinny and, I mean, bony,
想要推翻政府。这足以让他们杀你、让你失踪，或者对你做任何他们想对你做的事。有一次，帕特里夏的父亲失踪了好几个星期。他被军队或警察绑架了。帕特里夏的家人从未确切弄清楚是谁干的。他回家时已经瘦得脱了形，因为他太瘦了，我的意思是，只剩下骨头，
he had a beard so long, he didn't look at anything like my dad. But he'd made it back and with him he read a horrible story of torture. And things that had been done to him that were just inhumane. At that point Patricia's parents fled to Mexico City, leaving Patricia and her sister with their grandmother. Her parents said they'd be in touch when they had a plan. For two years, nothing. And then a letter from her mother.
他留着长长的胡子，一点也不像我爸爸了。但他确实回来了，随着他的归来，他讲述了一个关于酷刑的可怕故事。以及那些对他做过的极其不人道的行径。当时帕特里夏的父母逃到了墨西哥城，把帕特里夏和她的妹妹留给了祖母。她的父母说等他们有了计划就会联系。两年过去了，什么也没有。然后收到了她母亲的一封信。
And the letter said, you know, bring the girls to the border, bring them to this park and chap us, and I will be there waiting. Patricia enters sister across the border from Guatemala into Mexico and met their mom at a designated park. They learned that she'd met some Quakers involved in the sanctuary movement. The Quakers told the family they had to know their Mexico, where they were met by a Catholic priest named Father Ricardo Elford. He worked closely with Reverend V.
信里说，你知道的，把女孩们带到边境，把她们带到恰帕斯的这个公园，我会一直在那里等着。帕特里夏和妹妹从危地马拉跨越边境进入墨西哥，并在指定的公园里与妈妈会合。她们得知妈妈遇到了一些参与庇护运动的贵格会教徒。贵格会教徒告诉这家人他们必须了解墨西哥，在那里他们由一位名叫里卡多·埃尔福德（Ricardo Elford）的神父接待。他与法伊夫牧师密切合作。
He wanted to know what had happened in Guatemala. He wanted to know why we were wanting to come to the US. He said, you know, just tell me, you know, what went on. Because we want to bring you, we just want to know what we can do for you. And my mom told him everything had happened, that the two. And then he said, everything is going to be okay. Father Elford was vetting the family.
他想知道危地马拉发生了什么。他想知道我们为什么想要来美国。他说：“你知道的，只管告诉我，你知道的，发生了什么。因为我们想带你们来，我们只是想知道我们能为你们做些什么。”我妈妈把发生的一切都告诉了他，那两个……然后他说：“一切都会好起来的。”埃尔福德神父正在对这家人进行审查。
He was making sure they qualified as refugees. As the sanctuary network had grown, they'd had to develop a more formalized process. This was partly to ensure their limited resources went towards helping people who were most in need. It was also to try and ensure they weren't putting volunteers at risk or bringing someone dangerous into the US. One of the government's criticisms of the sanctuary movement was that they lacked the expertise and resources to evaluate potential refugees. The government worried they might be helping criminals enter the country, or communists who wanted to undermine the US government. Here's Reverend Fife again. I would just kind of smile and say,
他要确保他们符合难民的资格。随着庇护网络的扩大，他们不得不制定一个更加形式化的流程。这部分是为了确保他们有限的资源用于帮助最需要帮助的人。这也是为了尽量确保他们没有将志愿者置于危险之中，或者把危险人物带入美国。政府对庇护运动的批评之一是他们缺乏评估潜在难民的专业知识和资源。政府担心他们可能会帮助罪犯入境，或者是想破坏美国政府的共产党人。这里又是法伊夫牧师的话。我只会微微一笑说：
you don't understand the church. We have the best intelligence system in the world. As I understand it, what you say is you have five CIA agents in El Salvador right now. I have thousands. They're called priests and pastors, and all I have to do is pick up the phone and call them. And they'll give me the whole family history.
你们不了解教会。我们拥有世界上最好的情报系统。据我所知，你们在萨尔瓦多有五名中情局特工。我有成千上万个。他们被称为神父和牧师，我所要做的就是拿起电话给他们打电话。他们会把整个家族史告诉我。
One's father, Alfred, was satisfied that Patricia and her family actually met the requirements for refugee status. He arranged for them to be brought across the border into the U.S. We got picked up very early in the morning in this yellow truck. And we were thrown in the back right under lots of sleeping bags and they told us that no matter what we couldn't pop our heads up We just had to stay underneath
一位是阿尔弗雷德神父，他确信帕特里夏和她的家人确实符合难民身份的要求。他安排他们越境进入美国。清晨很早的时候，我们坐着这辆黄色的卡车被接走了。我们被扔在后车厢里，正好在大量睡袋底下，他们告诉我们，无论如何我们都不能把头探出来。我们只能待在底下
The family crossed into Douglas, Arizona and then headed to Tucson where they stayed at St. Michael's Episcopal Another church in town that had declared sanctuary After living there for six months, they moved into a house and started the long process of applying to stay in the U.S. It took them more than six years of legal wrangling to receive asylum. Patricia still gets emotional thinking about what the sanctuary movement did for her and her family. I remember my parents talking about this and saying, you know, who would do this? Who would risk their lives, you know, their good lives here in the US for people like us? But as the movement grew bigger and more visible, the whole endeavor became riskier.
这家人越境进入亚利桑那州道格拉斯，然后前往图森，住在圣迈克尔圣公会教堂——镇上另一家宣布提供庇护的教堂。在那里住了六个月后，他们搬进了一所房子，并开始了申请留在美国的漫长程序。他们经历了六年多的法律争端才获得庇护。每当想起庇护运动为她和她的家人所做的一切，帕特里夏仍然会情绪激动。我记得我的父母谈论这件事时说：“你知道的，谁会这么做？谁会为了像我们这样的人，冒着生命危险，冒着在美国的美好生活？”但随着运动越来越大、越来越引人注目，整个努力也变得更加危险。
Well, quite frankly, I never thought we were going to get away with this. Right. I mean, the first time I went to the border to do a crossing, 1981 sometime, I had to get comfortable with the fact that we weren't going to get away with this, that the government was going to come after us. And it was only a matter of time. John was right. It was only a matter of time.
好吧，坦白说，我从来没想过我们能逃过惩罚。没错。我的意思是，我第一次去边境进行越境时，大约是1981年的某个时候，我必须让自己习惯这样一个事实：我们无法逃脱惩罚，政府会来找我们的。这只是时间问题。约翰是对的。这只是时间问题。
And the religious motivations of the sanctuary movement didn't get much sympathy from the government. They have the right to think what they want. Anybody does. That doesn't exclude them from obeying the wells of the United States. Somebody could say, I think it's my religious right to rob a liquor store. And I think most of us would say, no, it's not.
庇护运动的宗教动机并未获得政府太多的同情。他们有权去想他们想的事。任何人都可以。但这并不排斥他们遵守美国的法律。有人可能会说：“我认为抢劫一家酒类商店是我的宗教权利。”我想我们大多数人会说：“不，这不是。”
Next week on 99% in visible, undercover government informants infiltrate the sanctuary movement. Yeah, a couple of these guys, I thought they don't fit the usual sanctuary volunteer profile, right? 99% invisible was produced this week by Delaney Hall with Serifusive, Avery Trollflamon, Emmett Fitzgerald, Sam Greenspan, and me Roman Mars. Our senior editor is Katie Mangle. Kurt Colstead is our digital director. Taren Meza is the office manager.
下周在 99% Invisible 中，卧底政府线人渗透进庇护运动。是的，其中有几个家伙，我想他们不符合通常的庇护志愿者形象，对吧？本周的 99% Invisible由德兰尼·霍尔与塞里夫西夫、艾弗里·特罗夫拉蒙、埃姆费·菲茨杰拉德、萨姆·格林斯潘以及我罗曼·马尔斯共同制作。我们的高级编辑是凯蒂·曼格。库尔特·科尔斯特德是我们的数字总监。塔伦·梅萨是办公室经理。
Sean Rial composed original music for this episode with additional music by Okakumi and Melodium, special thanks to Trent Party at the University of Arizona Special Collections in Jude Party. We are a project of 91.7 KALW in San Francisco and produced on Radio Row in beautiful Party. We are a project of 91.7 K-A-L-W in San Francisco and produced on Radio Row in beautiful downtown Oakland, California. You can find 99% invisible and join discussions about this show on Facebook. You can tweet at me at Roman Mars and the show at 99PI Org. We're on Instagram and Tumblr too.
肖恩·里亚尔为本集创作了原创音乐，奥卡库米和梅洛迪姆提供了额外音乐，特别感谢亚利桑那大学特藏馆的特伦特·帕蒂和裘德·帕蒂。我们是旧金山 91.7 KALW 的一个项目，制作于加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心美丽的美丽的无线电街。您可以在 Facebook 上找到 99% Invisible并参与关于本节目的讨论。您可以在推特上@我 Roman Mars，也可以@节目 99PI Org。我们在 Instagram 和 Tumblr 上也有账号。
But if you want to learn the subtle art of wilderness trail design, that is the textbook definition of invisible design. You have to go to 99PI.org. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
但如果你想学习荒野步道设计的微妙艺术，那将是隐形设计的教科书式定义。你必须去 99PI.org。这集节目目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。